partout au Québec au Nord comme au Sud
il a fait très chaud et humide au cours
des derniers jours et nous ne sommes pas
seuls on a battu des records de
température mondiale 4 journées
d'affilée cette semaine on le sait plus
le climat se réchauffe plus on augmente
la probabilité d'avoir des canicules
plus intenses et surtout plus fréquent
surtout en début de saison estivale un
découpable el ninio un phénomène
météorologique qui se caractérise par
des températures plus élevées dans
l'océan Pacifique et qui pourrait
conduire à de nouveaux records de
chaleur mais son retour s'inscrit dans
une tendance plus lourde vous voyez que
quand même une tendance sur imposée des
changements climatiques et ce depuis les
années 70 ou décennies après décennies
il fait de plus en plus chaud sur la
planète les événements climatiques
extrêmes récents comme les canicules et
les feux de forêts ont de quoi
bouleversé le quotidien de plusieurs et
inquiéter aussi moi ça me préoccupe
énormément ça me fait dire que on va
probablement frapper un mur bientôt
c'est un petit peu quand même pour le
futur je pense surtout à mon garçon
15 ans 20 ans ça va être que les feux de
forêts et tout
qui vivent de l'école anxiété et quand
on regarde chez les jeunes ça va à 50%
des jeunes qui vont ressentir de l'écho
anxiété c'est des émotions qui sont
normales c'est valide parmi les
solutions proposées par Anne-Sophie
Dorion s'impliquer dans sa communauté
individuellement et collectivement oui
il faut s'adapter à beaucoup de niveaux
ça peut être au niveau des villes du
gouvernement des individus et dans tout
ça ne pas oublier évidemment à continuer
à lutter contre les changements
climatiques en réduisant nos émissions
un moyen de limiter la fréquence des
prochaines vagues de chaleur ici ça a
des rires Radio-Canada Montréal